good evening ladies and gentlemen and
welcome back to
sgn i am john krasinski and that amazing
opening was brought to you by squad
harmonix
very clear evidence that i have waded
through the mighty river of unsolicited
criticism
and my ego has come out safely on the
other side or so i thought
this week a whole new curve ball was
presented when i fell
face first through the looking glass
into the what the actual heck is going
on world of fan art
that's right for someone who only just
got off dial up this week
this whole internet thing continues to
be a constant source of surprise
and living nightmares and finally
there's this four
paneler which i have to appreciate as
it'll be the closest i ever get
to playing a comic book hero
[Music]
in all sincerity it is an absolute joy
to see you all having as much
fun with this show as we are welcome
back everyone it's charlie a lot of you
sent me this clip of john krasinski on
his show recently talking about being
comic book characters and wondered what
this has to do with the reports about
him meeting with marvel recently so
we'll break it all down
there's a bunch of easter eggs marvel
and john krasinski
and his wife emily blunt have a long
time history
with marvel projects despite all of his
jokes recently they've been after him
for a long time
so if you're new to the channel we're
doing that amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know which marvel character
you want him to play
if you don't know what's going on he's
been doing this web show while
everyone's been trapped inside their
homes because of the lockdown and the
virus so he's been doing this
show and as he says in that clip he
waded into the world of fan art
because for as long as you can remember
seeing those john krasinski
fantastic four fan art pictures from so
many different places people have been
sending those to him
when he was doing press for his new
movie quiet place 2 earlier this year a
couple months ago he said that he still
wanted to play reed richards he hoped
that marvel would consider him he would
love to be in a marvel movie
all of his friends are in marvel movies
he's actually real life friends with a
lot of the mcu actors
so everyone saw this clip and then saw
him turn to camera and do that gem from
the office routine where he knows
something is up and he's just messing
with us like oh i'm never
ever going to be a comic book character
like he's completely sarcastic and he
will totally wind up being a comic book
character
and there were reports recently that
during the lockdown he's had virtual
meetings with marvel about a number of
different projects that means
a number of different characters number
of different movies and possibility of
him directing a marvel movie
so these would be my top five picks for
the movies that marvel might be after
him for to potentially star in and
direct and which characters those would
be
starting with number five there's
marvel's blade movie obviously they
already have their blade mahershal ali
they announced it they didn't announce
when they're releasing it but he could
be up to direct it i think he could pull
it off his quiet place films if you
haven't seen them
are really scary but they have these
sci-fi elements to them which feels like
something that marvel would get into
with the blade movies
a little bit sci-fi a little bit fantasy
a little bit horror
marvel hasn't really given any
indication as to who the villain of that
blade movie could be it could be dracula
it could be werewolf by night it could
be another big vampire character from
marvel comics
they could even work up to a crossover
with jared leto's morbius character if
that movie goes well but they've delayed
that at sony so we won't see morbius for
another year or so
right now just looking at the marvel
phase 5 schedule and the open dates that
marvel has there's an october 2022 date
where they could put the blade movie
because they tend to release the darker
movies towards the end of the year and
if you're going to introduce vampires to
the mcu
what better month than the month of
halloween to do it but even though
krazynski could totally pull off the
blade movie i'd rather see him do a
couple other big projects so that's why
blade is so low on my list here
so number four slightly more likely i
think marvel has reportedly been taking
pitches recently from writers and
directors for a young avengers disney
plus series
it'd be six episodes like all the other
marvel disney plus series and happens
sometime
after ant-man 3 which is reportedly
introducing some more young avengers
elements in addition to the other new
young avengers characters debuting on
other disney plus series we have cade
bishop hawkeye coming up on the hawkeye
series miss marvel she-hulk we have both
of scarlet witch's children wiccan and
speed that are gonna debut on the one
division tv show
we have cassie lang we have potential
for iron lad character or any other new
characters they want to introduce from
the comics
and even though most of my picks for
john krasinski's projects are
hero based characters the good
characters he could also pull off a lot
of the villains too
so with that in mind number three kang
the conqueror as part of that young
avengers project
they're supposed to be setting the
character up on the loki time travel
series
and tease him in some way it sounds like
marvel wants to use him as a big marvel
phase 4
phase 5 villain down the road so they
kind of want to set him up in these
early phase 4 projects
it'd be bold and unexpected but i think
he could do a great job with it but
that's also kind of why it's a little
bit lower on my list
in the past when marvel has been after
him for superhero roles it's been for
good characters
if you haven't heard the full story
originally he was up for the role of
captain america before they cast chris
evans chris evans was not their first
choice for
captain america having a big audience
for you must be a cool thing good for
you
i'm excited good for you you made it
chris we'll see how it comes you know
fingers crossed
krasinski tells this funny story about
how he totally lost his confidence when
chris hemsworth walked by him looking
super
ripped because this was around the time
that he just done the thor movie
i heard that you screen tested for
captain america
that's right in my head i got the part
so when you had that
test what was it like it was a big deal
for me because i mean first of all i
love those marvel movies i'm i love
superheroes
i love imagination um so uh when they
asked me to test they actually
allowed me to put on the suit i was on a
set it was all very interesting i feel
like as i'm talking about this someone
from marvel's
like i'm just like i'm not i'm not
allowed to talk about it all
yeah um but i remember the the only
bummer of it was
i was putting on the suit just watching
it i was like this is so amazing and i
got about right to my waist i was still
shirtless feeling pretty good about
myself it wasn't 13 hours yet but
it felt pretty good and all of a sudden
chris hemsworth walked by his thor and
he's like
that night and i went i'm good this is
stupid
that's okay i kind of think things went
down the way they were supposed to i
can't picture anyone else playing
captain america besides chris evans
but it's just a good example of how long
marvel has been after him to play a
character in the mcu
his wife emily blunt was originally
going to be black widow before scarlett
johansson was picked for the role there
was a big scheduling conflict
emily blunt couldn't do it that's why
they went to scar joe
so number two a little more likely
there's marvel's new x-men
reboot movie this is where we're getting
up into the big ticket characters
everyone's been waiting for
marvel phase 5 stuff he could totally
try his hand at directing an x-men movie
but i think the russos have kind of
called dibs on the new x-men reboot
movie they are taking a break from doing
marvel movies because they've done it
for so
long now but they did say that if they
came back for anything it would be to do
the x-men
reboot film or for marvel's secret wars
so they really love those characters and
they understand them which clearly they
do because they're such long time comic
book fans i would prefer that the russos
direct
the next x-men movie but the cool thing
about john krasinski is that he actually
has the range to play
leaders leadership characters or weird
loner anti-heroes
so my top picks if he were to play an
x-men character would probably be
someone like cyclops
maybe beast and even though i think he
could pull off a version of professor x
i just don't think that he has the right
look for that
in the same thing with wolverine i think
he could do a great performance as the
wolverine character but he just doesn't
quite have the right look for that
and he's even taller than hugh jackman
and people keep talking about doing a
comic book accurate version of wolverine
wolverine is really short if he were to
be comic book accurate this is what he
would look like standing next to the
other x-men
we know a little bit more about what's
going on with the new fantastic four
than we do with the new x-men characters
x-men are a little bit further off so
this new x-men movie would be
way way down the road which is why i
think it's probably less likely that
he's up for something like this
kevin feige kind of implied that the way
they're doing those new x-men characters
is they'll pop up in all kinds of
different places before they show up in
a new x-men movie it'll be like
spider-man showing up in civil war
in a cameo then going to spider-man
homecoming then crossing over into the
avengers films
so of course it should be obvious my
number one pick for john krasinski in
the mcu would be a fantastic four
project now i definitely think he could
pull off directing fantastic four but
because
doing a movie that big the way that
kevin feige is hyping it up is a really
big
reboot and stirring it as the main
character at the same time
just feels like way too much work for
any one human being to do
so if he does wind up doing a fantastic
four project at marvel he'll probably
just star in it as reed richards
but here's the thing most of the time
when actors get fan cast as characters
they don't wind up ultimately playing
that
character but he spent so much time in
his interviews earlier this year saying
that he would love to do
fantastic four he would love to do a
marvel project this could be one of
those exceptions so it's not outside the
realm of possibility
just in terms of origin story though i
think the simplest way you do that
is that you do the comic book origin
where they get hit by the cosmic wave
but it happens on nick fury's sword
space station from the spider-man far
from home post credit scene
and the way you explain how they got
there is that they're just sword agents
or scientists working on some special
project for nick fury so everyone let me
know in the comments
which projects do you think that john
krasinski was meeting with marvel for
which movies which disney plus series
which characters
it was a really big doctor strange two
announcement this past week you can
click here to learn all about that
really good news and click here for my
avengers infinity saga video for
incredible hulk
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you